R can handle a lot more
than numbers.
For example, you can handle
character objects, which are
also known as strings.
We can make a simple character
object just by putting some
text in quotation marks.
You might notice something we
saw before, which is that the
output is again preceded
by a 1 in brackets.
This character object is a
vector, and we can create a
longer vector using the
concatenate function.
As with numerical vectors, we
can apply functions to a
character vector to learn more
about it or get summary
information.
In addition to the numeric and
character type of vector, we
can create a Boolean vector.
In the simplest case, we can
write TRUE in all caps, or we
can write FALSE in all caps.
We can also create a vector of
TRUE and FALSE values using
the concatenate function.
One of the really handy features
of Boolean vectors is
that they can be used to extract
specific elements of a
vector that meet a
certain criteria.
For example, here I'll use the
NCHAR function to find out the
number of characters
in each character
string in the vector.
Then we're going to create a
new vector called under.10.
This vector will indicate which
elements of v have less
than 10 characters.
Finally, I can subset
v using under.10.
In the next video, we'll start
doing arithmetic with vectors.